you
okay we got 68 players for a trio turn
fifty-five Minotaur
you're going to have to plan your iPad
they're already 300 gainst a human oh
what's going on there we go
a d4 d5 exchange okay
let's sneak this in
okay my knight did his job
well then I'd have to worry about
essential expansion now there's no F fun
that's gonna scare me
I could break this button sooner but I
just want to make sure my bishop can get
here even if the night takes them out
I'm fine with that structure and oh
actually here's the other thing then
bishop has to give itself up for the
night because of this post
and how do I want to recapture is an
interesting question what's really I
don't believe that I don't believe that
clean exchange I'm going to try and
target this
when I play King f8 in here if the
Queen's are still on I don't wanna let
this rook leave so soon huh let's do
this right now
okay how to play h4
huh
alright let's try for this to get this
move in and then the night returning and
the I also make them think twice about
King G - because it was sacrifice on
there for like chopped chopped check and
then here pretty powerful square for a
knight this structure does a good job of
combating the knight so he's kind of a
queen side specific piece at the moment
and things may turn towards the Kings
side with these sacrifices
Queen here straightaway gets dislodged
the immediate challenge
so it's an opposite color Bishop
position interesting move I could play
this a nun chop I have that let's give
this a go
yeah the tactics also I could change the
structure here and then here let's try
for that this could be a pretty secure
home now for my king
tonight I know six is a rock I was he
really gonna get hunted down and I can't
challenge him okay so the king is much
weaker than mine
hmm I go here I'm gonna try this move I
want to force this and if here I take
and then the King has to take I just
didn't want to invite their queen
forward so easily okay so he's here to
stay
although he's gonna get hunted down now
okay I gotta shift gears I gotta play
against this over here and am I not
winning upon now actually yeah how are
these both defended
I don't see it I could take care
no bishop move with check
so just Queen takes pawn huh what am I
missing
right here and my Queens running short
on squares now I could always create a
square here and it's just off for a
queen exchange let's go here
I want my bishop to play he's not really
doing anything I don't see any
sacrifices see outs let's challenge him
okay stop set the night and I could try
for this actually let's do it now let's
keep pushing I can rely upon my queen as
a defender let's take let's go here okay
now to get my king
playing Eric's my rook line it's
connecting connecting rooks now okay
let's go here scarred my seventh so to
be concerned about pressure against
these points but I have everything
defended and now I get my King back over
here
as well
my knight needs to reposition
come on night look at the time they're
just winning that bomb
you
sixteen seconds push him right away
take that pond this pond can't be
stopped
you
and it's with Chuck
plenty of time back to Turman roof they
kicked it into a higher gear there
okay interesting structure on the
kingside there
yeah for sure
let's try Annie for a game Sicilian all
right let's try check Bishop black I'll
try a for saying I'm cool with BB pawns
because my Rick will be happy
okay
devoting my queen to e2 right now
now take
try to let's do this straight away
actually this could be an idea but I'll
be there in time to have my Bishop
defend I'm playing against this square
I want my knight on c4 he can rely upon
this square because of this idea
if this that actually drops d6 but I'll
be looking for this move if this this
squares weakened I'll think more about
giving up a bishop for night in
functioning on the d5 square these are
two very good squares so right now if
this I'm looking at this and then he's
there to stay he can't be dislodged with
this idea a six is met with that and now
that move I feel like this is a
strategic win will take with this it
frees up my half pawn now and I could
play this but I don't know if I want to
open up this diagonal what's the winning
way probably this here and then b4 let's
try for that
maybe even I maybe even I may even be
able to play before at this moment yeah
I could also I might get a little bit
greedy but I believe I could also just
win the pond straight up
yeah you know I like my bishop too much
no
this isn't a tactic because I'm still
there defending with my Queen and the
Queen can actually cannot even move and
defend here I was thinking the Queen
could go here
so now this pond is really
job on the queenside ponds in the plan
here is to just put pressure on b7 sneak
in a flight square this actually might
be the fly square a light squares is
fine this combats against a Knight f4
idea
looking at these forward moves and at
some point I may I may go ahead and do
that move I probably should have done it
before recapturing but I still I'm a big
fan of my position here good control
he's not contributing
I could also look at this idea with this
move
they're at the 52nd mark team match
thank you for the 30 months in a row man
okay I'm gonna go in for this no smash
through a b2
Queens very short on squares I'll sneak
in a flight square next Oh either a
mouse slipper they just missed I was
controlling d6
what's up skylight RS I'm doing alright
tonight it's a cold one in PA for sure
single digits or maybe just an hour or
two away from single digits now
all right we got a deef or a game
let's try g3 some g3 system ok heading
for a Catalan land
I'll take he's not going to be around to
recapture
you know
supa three three three is the opponent
its castle what's PA is a question in
the chat Pennsylvania
let's capture keeping the structure
Oh actually there's some serious issue
isn't there
and I have that one move sooner after b6
I probably should have jumped in I don't
know
Bishop takes you know you could block oh
you know what I do have though here and
after this I have rook tix instead of
winning upon with Bishop takes
Tom takes
takes I take with the rook and then the
bishop and then where's he going
rook takes his best
I'm also on this
okay I could uh could grab here first
this is I'm broken down and winning the
house back to tournament gonna be taken
him with
check her Oni
you think so Nobby
be a most beautiful state
in the Union
all righty Asha taco let's play c4 let's
go with g3 again all righty
shooting for d4
you gotta challenge those guys as soon
as possible no time to counsel otherwise
my night if I did cows on my night gets
scared away council only now
and weird is my dark square bishop
belong when I got here here just gets
asked a question
let's get another piece involved
at some point I could capture okay let's
sneak this in
I still have defended he too defended
with my c3 Knight so now this is an
opportunity for Knight c4 Knight f5
isn't it can also go for this and then
playing on the c5 square
you
here d4 and I go for something simple
playing against us this this structure I
have b8 under control I would have b3
anyhow
and I'm also prepared to just drop the
bishop back I want a dark square Bishop
at this at this point and then to put my
knight on c5 and my queen on D form
eventually once my Bishop isn't going to
stabilize the night for starters once I
could be assured that my Bishop isn't
going to be trapped after I do something
like III well I'm not saying that I want
to I want to make sure my Bishop doesn't
get trapped when I play e3 so something
like this first get out of the pen and
then III
um let's go here maybe I want to step up
with my queen next
well I let these pawns I allowed them to
start to move ok Queens off they're
dropping upon now if he becomes too much
of a bug on this diagonal I could play
g4 I've no worries at this stage now
drop in a full rook back to tournament
lands okay we're in third I got 12
there's 98 that's a pretty good turnout
for a created one I see batter bombs is
in there total analysis gunner three
zero four chest oscar own is there
hyeme gosu version 2 is there as well
some
count
is in first whoo let's try d6 in g6
okay
to this earlier in the stream
all right let's go Knight f6 now at some
point I could do that and the other
point is that now I could shop
and then challenge this duo have enough
support for d5
where's the bishop gonna go okay
I'm okay with this bishop for a night
exchange because this is a super a super
static structure I don't see how it
changes maybe just on the Queen side
once b5 is in well that's a long way off
so let's just secure a nice structure
and this night is actually gonna go here
here he's vulnerable and the other
points worth having the night here is
that he combats the night from a four
this is one of the most sensitive
squares in my position in reach of the
night the rook the pond
he's secure now my queen is free to go
somewhere else
let's try here I guess stopping night a
for I don't care
there's no attack against my king
with the dark square bishop exchange
there's only one active piece the Queen
and that's not enough and I have two
Knights around that could help defend at
the same time I just I still don't want
to invite the Queen it's gonna this rook
he has a responsibility and some lines
on a six
come on b2 have a good king position
this is actually a bit tempting
not really
though who could improve
I also just double
see how they deal with the pressure
against b2 can't play b3
and my queen has pressure on a two as
well so the rook moves then the knight
can't move and if they do this then I
have the be three square so can I take
advantage of that mouth
I'll sneak over here it's an open file
a little bit of a time edge
very weakening g6 okay we're just gonna
come over here okay the night is heading
for these squares I guess or this square
what's real that one out I don't I'm
gonna get rid of my night
okay now that's highly committal highly
committal I couldn't make use of the
okay that move there's no way that could
be correct
oh they're threatening Queen here also I
could target this weak point I have him
under control with this name
let's keep pressure here and I'm ready
to sneak over my queen starts to cut in
its some squares near the King my pieces
start to converge near the White King
definitely taking with the night and now
this is decisive my night getting into
f4 with the Queen still on the board
even if they're not on the board let's
just and get out of the line of fire for
starters I'm in a pin I should have
actually played Queen d6 first I was
stupid
so first okay actually I could chase the
Queen away with this move even on the
clock I have a check in the position
rook g5 now we sneak over move the rook
back or not even let's just go all-in
over here
all in piling up on the H pon 30 seconds
this is a move this this was already
moving the last turn but there's no
there's no defense here so I could still
do this I feel like there's something
better though yeah I I can I just I like
my night yeah I could take here first
with check actually losing material ah
this is sad
oh no I could defend the rook like that
I got a hurry though I had a had a night
move no bishop
with check
let's just trade
yeah let's just try
tomorrow know what kind of move was
there
no stalemates okay
yeah my heart was uh
I kind of skipped a beat there with that
Queenie five move I thought I had to
give up my night
okay a knight h5 defends f4
all right let's start with d5
d5 Knight f6
what's that pond gonna do he's not going
to be contributing it's just a fin here
pawn trio how will white combat this
that way huh alright let's develop and
show the squares
okay what's the story with this move
let's get ready to kick this night away
or force force this capture I'm also
it's not just to force this but get my
bishop on the long diagonal take with
the night
after the smoke clears
I'm a very nice center a lead in
development and he's going to struggle
start with that okay so under developing
this makes me want to smash things open
right away but let's just continue to
build this advantage isn't going
anywhere just adding to it bringing more
pieces in but now really is the time to
break I believe let's get this I'm just
I'm going to continue to build
I help white out in a way with the
bishop Queen here put the rooks on the
center I didn't go here because of that
be for a movie I'll I'm gonna stay
opposite the king you know this might
have been better
yeah
can still try for that well
I'm giving up upon I don't like how I
played these last handful of moves I
could win
a sick spawn so on a check you're
blocking with the Queen even so I'm
gonna do this getting that pawn pack
yeah I'll take him I have this square to
work with and grab another pawn oh my
god
really
you
if I took there was rook here
my queen is pinned sharp move man sharp
move
you
clean exchange
yep and I'm
time on two three four five le of a pond
they have an extra piece
all right let's see if this pawn can
score
touchdown
now we're gonna advance let's go King
you
here and then h3 let's see what they do
on the clock here quality has gone down
let's go one more my King might go even
further 11 seconds
I'm just gonna win on time
you
oh I thought I was going to be able to
win on time
let's just make sure I don't get made
Wow
felt like the beginning I don't know
that was a weird game
weird
okay we are at 20 27 2120 I'm goes to v2
is in a game 117 aren't here very nice
Jukes ooh
let's try you for a French
strain 8c3
okay let's try it turn it into a
Sicilian Grand Prix land well they made
it Sicilian let's go Grand Prix on a
Grand Prix action bishop on c4
you
let's do a three a three Bishop c2
Bishop a - okay
this was one of my concerns that's why
plate a3 first Bishop c4 Knight here a3
then there's d5
all right they'll be able to play b5
with tempo I'm looking to attack on the
kingside with this maneuver n f5 and
Bishop h6
that's the plan exchange off their
master minor piece
and third square
as an animal
let's go for it
so this is just a clearance it's a pawn
sacrifice in order to eliminate the
bishop
follow up moves of Knight g5 Bishop
takes Queen takes leading to mate and
that stuff let's back up if I take
it opens up the diagonal
now I have an interesting decision I
think
[Music]
I'm gonna take with the pawn because I
still want to get this in
it forced black to take with a pawn and
at the same time I want to make sure
this Knight doesn't have nice squares I
form a pawn duo this is definitely the
move that's concerning me most
everything is on that so here striking
at this but I might just ignore it in
playoff five anyhow yeah
this is kind of lame
let's try this if you take like this my
bishop is seeing the world a little bit
more
he reaches f7 instead of e6 if you take
like this that's a very weakening move
all that said let's still going for this
plan
of attacking
of the better queen position
one minute 12
black and
Black's just in time now is that the
thing
so if I do this there's a night move
here
let's take the bishop first
what about night here right now it's
different story now because I get I got
here the strata is mating one Queen
takes h7
okay
what's the count here I'm down upon
I'm expecting night here yeah there
defending with
precision I think exchange queens and
win this phone
now keep the Queen's on still defense c2
maybe a timely kick like this
let's go here Wow
okay
let's do this
yeah men
this is this is very good defense
very good defense I take with the Queen
there's night here
[Music]
I gotta kick it into a higher gear
I got to just want the Queens off man
can we get the Queens off
gun a little slower can you get the
Queen's off now they blundered now they
blundered
tell you what before that everything
seemed flawless all right close to it
back to tournament 35:26 24 18 and
change
okay I am gosu veto is still in first
and is in a game with total analysis
no speed bump see they're all wins all
righty
okay here we go
I have a chance to come back I
definitely need to win here
I think the games that we've played are
just all out 1 1 o games
let's try this 92 to g3 ok
will I be allowed to play h5 No
let's play play Bishop ear for starters
Queen here and then night here I guess
is the idea
Queen here my thought is that at some
point I could play Knight b5 and this is
sensitive just want to secure this
square
now maybe I exchanged the bishop's it's
tough to say with the you know good and
bad bishops in a position like this
he needs to reposition for sure unless
there's a sacrifice here sometimes that
could be the case without the pawn on f3
bishop in that converging but I don't
think so here so I'm going to set my
sights on kind of controlling d5 in the
event of c6 or even b5 I have b5 under
control of c6 I could add some more
support Knights very good from this
square the same time I don't want to do
this too fast because of a move like
that you know my bishop doesn't have a
good square but I think going here is
fine I don't need my Queen defending any
squares have this one under control my
queen is pulled away from the Queen side
and let's just go straight in for this
five or not think you have to
alright or castling on this move I just
stay put with these guys
if I play this the night as a jumping
point even if that if isn't hitting what
a fork I don't want to allow the night
an avenue to get into d4 so this is
typical of queenside castle and what now
Oh actually I could take here
because I'm on this square and then hop
in here maybe I was too fast with that
no I don't want to jump in too soon hmm
let's try this here and then here
here's one thing if the Queen goes too
far away I have this idea of 9f5 chop
Queen g5 check and then I pick up the
night
back up he controls this square so my
bishop currently offsets the knight has
an influence if black ever considers f5
have a big time edge and from here maybe
I could just kind of weasel around a
little bit
yeah this would actually threaten this
move right now just kind of poking
around see if I could get something I
wouldn't mind seeing a queen exchange
who
I don't like how I played these last
handful of moves let's try this yeah
push now I have some concern here the
rooks are really quick to double so
let's take like this jump in like that
and then I get I force the Queen
exchange the Queen exchange is avoided
then I have this so maybe now there's
this move
this doubling up is a is an issue
it looks really passive but I think it's
correct oh god am I getting mated with a
knight here
don't make me
whatever you do don't make me man
my cane needs to get out and play my
night is fortunately a very strong piece
even if they hunt down that pond yeah
let's get rid of him I'll take with the
king and hang on to that pond my knight
covers a lot of ground yeah a lot of
ground let's just offer a rook exchange
I'm up upon
you know this is winning
you
let's get my night on a different square
you
okay I can get a passed pawn over here
am i pushing through
and just block the bishop
okay yeah once it got tricky like that
at the end with those pawn pushes there
wasn't time to calculate the important
wind 28 with fire two games maybe three
more in there
we'll see
129 are in here how are you gonna get
next ok the guy that's in first is not
playing so I guess we're gonna get
paired up no
ivar code
I'm playing team black
okay let's try Sicilian
I might need to try a fishing pole game
I could use a quick win
quick win
quick tricks
a ch3 kick my night away he runs into
trouble with that and also this
could have landed a Forex straightaway
but it's still there
got to do this it's the only move or no
no I'm sorry there's a bishop move
is this a movie night here here chopped
shop I'm hitting the bishop in the pond
but then there's Bishop f4 to defend
both that move however
I think Queen here or actually just
night here is winning
actually we're gonna run it like this
we're gonna pick up the exchange
oh there's they had something different
actually they could have attacked they
should have captured with the King to
get out of the pin so I'm currently up
the exchange and I'm gonna win this guy
for nothing really there's no night move
to defend him and there's no pawn move
to support him and he's blocked out
because of f4
so they should probably resign this one
hopefully they'll resign I'll see
the correct way to address that early
Knight g4 move is I believe to just play
g3
and then kick them away one move later
so let's see there's nine minutes left
in this tournament
hun is down to a minute 18
and we're taking with the night looking
for some more exchanges here I just
dropped back don't want to give this
square up
just take a piece
I could go here let's do that
I'll go here if it's with tempo
maybe Neil
and I was ready to go here let's not do
that
it's not for a queen exchange I want to
get my bishop here controlling this
square
let's do this and control that
let's just stay around over here he's
gotta go let's get my rook out of danger
now let's go here actually no here
defend the bishop I want to do this and
then castle
I was thinking this to stop queen here
just ask him a question
and I might give out some material back
clean here
chop-chop-chop
now let's just do like this here then
castle
just want to get my rook playing Bishop
d4 next
okay now this rook is shut out
now I don't want to castle
okay they gave me something there in
time pressure 35 35 32 6 minutes 32
seconds
do I need to preserve a game here
how's his game looking okay he's playing
he's paired up with the number-one guy
it's looking good for team white
this pond is gonna be won and I am
paired up I'm gonna try berserk game try
to get two more games in there
I should have tried for something
sharper
I am up upon
let's chase him away
hands okay what next
what's that Bishop up to let's go here
looking at c5 I should have played night
here let's do that now
looking at g5 and then capturing away
here I want to do without g5 I think
it's castle I like my night where he's
out
58 seconds Wow
you
okay Bishop to b5 okay I know my knight
is cut off
holy comment
holy cow min let's close it close shop
here Bishop takes Knight as a move I'm
ready to give up the exchange
38 seconds is not a lot
you
you
night their cheese look at the threats
man
on the night I can I see that I missed
that
well I was also on their night there
just wanna sacrifice the rook is there
to defend laterally 27 ticks
okay
giving me the Queen
you're scaring me in the beginning for
sure
you
okay they resigned back determine three
minutes left I have 37 39 39 37 35 and
the player who is still in a game so my
opponent my next opponent could always
known a fry me
just play a regular one budapest gambit
this is uh
in opening that Howard Stern is a fan of
Howard Stern plays chess yes he does
okay well he did at least let's open up
his eyes
mmm-hmm let's kick him away now I want
the night to get in the way of this rook
maneuver
so uh-huh let's try
step up you can't go here now look
still don't want to let you go here I
don't want you to do what you want to do
I'm not concerned about that should I be
push in the center Queen h4 g3 my
experience playing against opponents who
play the Budapest's they know a lot of
tricks
for sure
and I just really weak in my light
squares I might need to stop him from
doing anything yeah so I'm giving up a
square but there isn't tonight around
the bishop is a little ways off just
wanna kind of cut the communication
Space Invader pawns 40 seconds left I
don't think this one's finishing okay so
now I just I want some peace here I
don't see how I pull that off though
where's the next pawn break
I know here keep pressure here and I
want to reposition my bishop I feel like
I get four so the win of the exchange
this truck is pretty short on squares
all right let's see
that's light time edge what's he gonna
do these guys are in his way and this
structure here does a good job combating
the bishop the space advantage is really
felt interferes with the bishops the
rook is disconnected
let's try reposition see where the rook
goes yeah I mean he is he's just dead
I may win him for free now he could
always go back here
I just dropped this pawn
a minute five and then I can't do this
move
whoops are they going to see that
no they missed that so now we go here
cut into these squares and about a rook
up and over
some even trades
hunts and stuff the bishop from going
here for starters
he's pinned there's no rook takes Bishop
I'll take it's a bad piece I'll take
giving the bishop a diagonal but I'm
gonna get the Queen's off soon I was
saying I wanted a piece here I'm a
moment away from that Queens are now
gone I'll take like this because I want
to target him and not allow c6 plenty of
approaches here and I'm gonna give him
up oh I just want to do that to activate
my rook they were in pre-move mode
though all right back to tournament land
those are the final standings 43 37 35
the player who
how new is this account created just
tonight now August 12th not squeaky
clean somebody got him
somebody slowed him down for a bit
took first four with 4337 hi I'm go
su-35 138 in hall that was a very nice
turnout
very nice let's see how the pages for a
created tournament
very cool you know what do we normally
cut
hmm maybe like I like it was doubled
this time
hey this penguin penguin joined and then
didn't play what's up with that
gotta play all right
- the 137 of you good games off
you